you seem to be conflating an opinion
with a preference do you understand the
distinction between the two there is a
distinction between the two but that's
not the connotation which I was using
well you were saying an opinion is
subjective right in the way that a
preference is subjective you know I like
vanilla more than chocolate that would
be a preference that's not what an
opinion is an opinion is when you make a
statement of fact from your perspective
so here's how I would show you an
example well that gets into the whole
like alternative fact realm you don't
you can make a a proclamation about what
you perceive the world around you to be
and that can be your opinion but there's
a specific distinction between opinion
and a fact now you can say that like uh
a preference and an opinion are similar
in that they're both subjective that
doesn't mean that necessarily they are
the same thing they're not both
subjective because a preference can't be
wrong whereas an opinion can be wrong so
for instance I can say I think that the
moon is made of green cheese it is my
opinion that the moon is made of green
cheese that is my opinion but it's wrong